les commissaires ont mis deux ans et
demi à préparer leur volumineux rapport
ils ont entendu 230 témoins dont
plusieurs membres de la GRC
tous ensemble
les défis et les causes fondamentales de
violence dans nos activités
la moitié des recommandations vise de
graves lacunes que la GRC doit corriger
disent les commissaires l'organisation
n'était pas prête à intervenir lors de
la tragédie de port-à-pitre et la mal
communiqué les informations à l'interne
et la mal avertit la population du
danger résultat conclut les commissaires
c'était le chaos sur le terrain alors
que le tireur déguisé en nageant de la
GRC et au volant d'une réplique d'une
autopatrouille se faufiler pour s'enfuir
et tu es 22 personnes
je suis contente frère d'une victime les
gens ont été entendus les victimes
n'auront pas perdu la vie pour rien
l'avocat de Lisa Benfield conjointe du
tireur dit que sa cliente est encouragée
par le rapport
il y a des changements significatifs
notamment pour aider les victimes de
violences conjugales tous ceux et celles
qui ont été directement touchés je suis
profondément désolé le commissaire par
intérim de la GRC promet des changements
en profondeur que le public pourra
suivre en ligne
pour m'assurer le suivi les
recommandations qui sont faits le
Premier ministre Justin Trudeau a
assisté à la présentation du rapport à
trujo il s'engage à donner suite aux
recommandations des commissaires c'est
certain que il va devoir avoir des
changements qui vont en avoir mais on va
prendre le temps de les faire de la
bonne façon puis on va garder des
familles évidemment au centre de tout ce
qu'on fait maintenant que la Commission
a terminé son enquête et que les leaders
ont promis des changements les familles
espèrent pouvoir enfin penser leur plaît
ici Michel Bridoux Radio-Canada Trudeau